foreign
[Music]
what's up fellas and fellette well I
used to I I do I do not like when people
do that but you know
um
it's what it is welcome to the you know
it's like look I'm gonna be in Charlotte
I'm gonna be in Knoxville I'm gonna be
in Little Rock Arkansas coming up here
National Calgary Edmonton
Ottawa Montreal Hamilton
um and uh and that's where I'm gonna be
coming up so you can go to chrisley.com
get those tickets
um and then also we've got beautiful uh
merch that you can go to chrislea.com we
got those Pockets stay deep teas and
um the pants that look absolutely
gorgeous we've got uh the hoodie that is
the pockets stay deep hoodie that are
absolutely gorgeous we've got grower die
hoodies two different styles absolutely
gorgeous and a bunch of different life
rips colorways go to chrislea.com for
some absolutely gorgeous merch thank you
very much and without further Ado
welcome to this
week's episode of congratulations
[Music]
you know I've been thinking first of all
like subscribe we love it
um we love it my babies uh but yeah dude
I've been thinking about I look here's
the deal I've I have to succumb
to the
family life and get I think well I'm
trying to here's a deal dude I've got
a car for I've got my my wife has a car
all right and it's a it's a great car
and it's well it's an rsq8 which is
awesome it's an awesome car you know I
bought it and was like got a new car and
she's like okay she doesn't care she's
the kind of person that doesn't
understand
what a like dude we'll be at the VA like
a valet we could valet her car and then
go back and get it and she'll be like
is that my car and it's not her car and
you're just like
you're in it all every day so like and
it's like but she's like well it's black
and it has the things on it and you're
just like yeah but you know what I mean
it's another four circles in the front
and also it's not your car
so um I got the car she doesn't want to
get the windows tinted so it doesn't
look as mean it doesn't look as mean I
want it to be it's all black I want it
to be mean right I want it to be mean
you started up because
and dude I want it to be mean she
doesn't want it to be mean she doesn't
want to be tinted because I get it my
cars are so tinted that it's crazy you
got to roll down the windows to pull out
right
um
so
so I I she doesn't get them tinted so I
you know
so she wants so we got the car we got we
don't have a lot of room in the driveway
because we're in our house now
whatever this is not relatable to
anybody in the world but um
I'm still telling you because this is a
cult congratulations and we love it and
you listen and we love you
um but yeah we my basically what I'm
starting to just come around to
I need a minivan
that's it dude I need to get a minivan
and I've been on this minivan train
and I'm like babe let's get a minivan
and she's like dude I'm cool still and I
said well then what car what you you
still want to be cool Mom what car do
you even have
she has no idea and it's like one of the
it's the most awesome car
rsq8 is so dope it's so ill
and she's like hey
I still want to be cool okay what card
do you have
she's got no idea
so
I'm like so let's get a minivan and
she's like well I'll say you could keep
your car we don't have the room but we
could park it on the street whatever you
know
and she's like well let's look at
minivans dude so we look at best minivan
because dude here's the deal man I got
an electric bike from Super 73 which is
so cool I took it out
and dude it's so cool that like
I can't I don't it doesn't fit in any of
my any of the cars so like I'm like I'm
gonna get a minivan for the car but
she thinks it's for the I'm gonna get a
minivan for the electric bike she looks
for the family it is I'm joking but you
know no one I'll ever know it's inside
my head not yours so
um so I went so I were looking at
minivans and dude the [__] KIA
Carnival one looks pretty dope the KIA
Carnival one looks pretty cool
and I think that's gonna be the one dude
and I have to look at them I have to
look at like uh what do you call it um
the different ones like they're they're
trying to people are like oh get the
[__] Chrysler not Chrysler nothing
dude Chrysler straight up nothing dude
you ever seen Chryslers with the wings
in the front no that looks that looks
Grandpa [__] dude it didn't Chrysler
make the PT Cruiser dude my dad rented a
PT Cruiser once and I go like this ah
dad dude yo no he was how old must have
he must have been I don't know but it
was so bad the PT Cruiser oh my God at
that point maybe worst car of all time
severely it I mean it's been trumped
since then but yo the PT Cruiser dude oh
it looks like like it's like a Dick
Tracy style [__] Dick Tracy mushroom
style thing it's just so bad if you look
it up some of you might not even know it
they made it for like three years
um Chrysler makes some [__] terrible
cars huh yeah all good uh make Chrysler
get it together hey you got Christ in
the name make it way better okay
um Christ should be the best right
um so yeah so I'm gonna get I want to
get a I want to get a minivan I think
but I want to Black it out that's the
thing about me is whatever I get I want
to make it the illest version of it
I'm just like dude can we put a spoiler
on the back of a [__] minivan let's
get us let's I bet you can actually I
went to a team one is what the one I
want
dude you know what I'll get it I'll get
a um
uh Kia Carnival is it Carnival or
Carnival Carnival uh whatever Carnival
and I'm gonna put that I'm gonna paint
it like the 18 ones just but myself me
and Calvin are gonna do it
um
anyway it's a cool car
but it's still a minivan and I get that
but it's like maybe they're so
convenient dude you gotta break every
now and then you got two kids you gotta
break right
maybe I should just only get the minivan
and that's it and just we should just
have one car that would be [__] kind
of ill and just honestly put Furniture
in there they're big dude just kind of
live in it
you know you can straight up get
minivans with like [__] honestly
Furniture in there you could get them
first of all optioned with seats that
are like you could either have them like
six seven or eight seats and then you
could have some seats like facing the
other way you could have a desk in there
with like [__] sconces
and then there's one with the
kitchenette
that I think Honda makes
it doesn't have a full you know thing
like no garbage disposal but you could
very much just open the window and toss
the chicken buns out
um
so that's me
about the the minivans
saw the [__] best looking dude ever
like a few days ago it was Troublesome
dude
here's here's the thing
here's the thing the guy was so good
looking that I go like this is how good
looking the dude was first of all taller
than me Whoopsie Daisy right not my
fault I'm tall I'm a tall Drinker what
do you know how tall I am I'm six two
I'm almost six I might be six three I'm
six four in heels and
so I'm I'm I'm at arawan which by the
way I wouldn't have gone there if I knew
I had been going already I didn't know
it was nowhere backwards and I I've
already spent like thousands of dollars
of arawan now over the years and it's
like now it's nowhere backwards and so
I'm like all pissed off I wouldn't have
done I wouldn't have gotten into your
cute [__] if I had known
and then they made fun of it in the show
you
they did this whatever it was there it's
called like
something and it was backwards it was a
take on Arrow one but
I'm at arawan and dude you know there
it's like hot chick City it's like hot
it's a hot person City you know
and I'm there and I walk in and I see
this woman that's like oh wow hey dude
hey I just wanted to be like you know
what hey hey Pat her on the back go get
him dude you got it you're so lucky hey
don't do anything extra just be you got
it you won a genetic Lottery don't do
[__] extra you know what I mean you
don't have to do don't go get a law
degree you know a lot of these hot
chicks feel like they have to like you
know prove themselves why bro if I could
come back as a dumb [__] model
like like a like a 5 10 you know what I
mean not even a tall one because they
look weird in pictures but like a 510
photogenic angular shaped veed out dude
with like a maybe even a small [__] you
don't know because I don't do nude stuff
but like super chiseled without even
working out and like when somebody says
what's up I go like this hey like that
kind of dude forget it I'm dude if I
could come back as a dumb [__]
that's it
that's me dude
just dumb as [__] in a gap ad with
another older guy you know what I'm
talking about
that's me man just come back dumbish and
I mean [__] straight up
like I can't I'm not gonna say the word
but I I don't mean like actually but
like almost to where I'm like one IQ
thing
above
you know what I'm saying right
and uh
like to where I just go like I I don't I
don't really know to most stuff right
no this is how I describe stuff like
I'll be like man that's crazy and they
but what do you mean and I say you know
it's just like crazy like that's the
kind of guy I am like so dumb I can't
even describe what I'm already talking
about I could talk about the thing I
want to talk about but I can't describe
what I'm talking about like those shoes
are so dope they're good for basketball
players what do you mean you know like
they're good for basketball players like
that's how I describe everything that's
the kind of dumb [__] I want to
be worse than someone with Down Syndrome
because not that people with Down
Syndrome are bad but worse than that you
know smart wise because at least people
with Down Syndrome you go like oh well
they got
you know they got down syndrome this guy
doesn't have Down syndrome and he still
doesn't know how to describe stuff
anyway dude I'm getting a lot of trouble
with what I'm saying it doesn't matter I
don't care at all dude
but
um that's how that's how I want to come
back one degree smarter than someone
with
Down syndrome you know I'm trying to not
do it but the bit is kind of just what
it is and that's that's that dude
like I put out you know what I'm done
I'm actually done because here's the
deal on Tick Tock you know we go dummy
viral on that [__] like just stupid
viral
and uh I went I posted this clip this
old clip from congratulations about
Italians and how they get mad and this
[__]
lady
said to me
where is it come on we're I'm finding it
oh I can't find it she said oh basically
what she did what she said oh where
where you should oh here it is stop
calling Italian Americans who have one
relative long Dead who visited into
Italy once by the way is that a that's
not uh the whole sentence right stop
calling Italian Americans
who have one relative long Dead who
visited Italy once that's not a whole
that's not the whole thought so I said
calling them what your sentence isn't
finished and she said
I had time today it is no Italian ever
is called Vinnie in extremists at least
say Italo Americans but not Italian and
I wrote no
and she said
uh okay fair enough it's not you who has
to deal with stereotypes coming from
people that have nothing to do with your
daily cheers yeah I don't know anything
about people [__] supposing [__] on
me
that that isn't true and by the way and
then I wrote yeah I don't care sorry
wouldn't have done that in 2018 whoa he
was pushed don't push me baby dude he
wouldn't have done that in 2018.
[Music]
dude so
um anyway
that's all I want to come back as a dumb
[__] so these chicks they don't
don't be doing anything just relax man
relax enjoy life get some [__]
kombucha you know what I mean get a nice
hoodie and just snuggle up in your
[__] cute pants right you know how
they do it with the blankets or get
those [__] sleeves that come over
your palms you know like it's like
you're cozy like you don't know it's
cute but you know it's cute dude hey
what's up and you're doing it like this
and you're [__] you know what you
know it's cute dude I had a diner while
I'm eating a breakfast burrito and
you're just like this you know what's up
man the [__] out of here right
but you don't know because the [__]
sleeves are long over your palms and you
know what's up you know you're
activating it man
right
but you all but you're being normal but
what I'm just yeah you know what's up
but anyway I obviously have some [__]
issues but it's like
dude
so I'm walking to arawan and I see this
I mean dude if I I mean you know what
she who she was like she was like
a cast member of the god of gods of
Egypt remember that [__] movie with
uh
Nikolai from
uh Game of Thrones and Gerard Butler
and she would be like a Casper every the
chicks in that
wowie you know and this woman is an
arrow and I walk in I go wowie I just go
wowie man
hey my head I just go wowie excuse me
you know the kind the kind of hot where
you just you see and you just go like
this
and you want to just clear a table of
like glassware
like you like you literally like the
[__] uh like somebody killed your
your witness to the crime that you were
about to [__] take to a case
we have no case now
that's how hot she was
and then I go and I order my two roasted
Salmons you know how I do it with a
little bit of white rice and some greens
you know how I do it and you know how I
do it because I keep it lean dude
I keep it lean that's why my body looks
like the current affair [__] logo
right
upside down maybe I don't know I think
it's a triangle but upside down you know
what I'm talking about
and um
so I eat the roasted I get the roast
this time I look over next to her dude I
see this dude
he's about six five long hair long like
a beard a little bit like an olive skin
dude this is how hot he was he looked
like he was a Native American but he
wasn't
[Music]
dude you ever seen a white guy that
looks Native American but isn't
I do we gotta get out of here pack it up
hold on a second we gotta pack this out
here
get get it going ah [__] A guy walks
into the club he's Native American but
what but not though you just think he is
and he's actually white and he's six
four okay dude we got it you know what
let's pack it up
here yeah we gotta go dude the guy's
here he's gonna get out get all the
chicks hey let's pack it up here take
the bottles there here let's go dude but
Nellie's on it doesn't matter yeah but
we're at the club and we still have
vodka live leave it for him it doesn't
matter he can get him he can get the
chicks great he's here dude [__]
Turok is here awesome dude that's it
that that's for real I swear to God
that's how and I I see the dude and I go
oh well okay I get it
dude I'd even look at the girl again I'm
all eyes on the on the dude
this guy was so hot I go like this
I lost
so uh that's that's how hot the dude was
that the hot chick
she was like she all of a sudden I saw
the hot dude and she goes like this I
feel funny Mr Stark dude she's gone
I don't feel so good Mr star and then I
look at this dude he's the only one left
uh
um
so that's what's up
I took I went to go pick up
um my wife from the from the airport
because I wanted to see her and she was
like I'll just get a ride home I was
like nah dude I want to see you
I want to see you as soon as you land
I'm gonna be there
but she was like really wanted to see
Calvin and it was like she landed at 9
30 and that's past his bedtime you know
but I was like Calvin let's go
and he was like you wanna go to bed or
you want to go pick up mommy with me and
he said I'll go pick up Mommy
so I put him in the back seat drove him
to the thing right William's sleeping at
home
I didn't leave him alone he there was
somebody there and uh
and we're getting we're going to the
airport and Calvin is just being such a
good dude he's not even like full not
falling asleep dude my favorite thing
about a kid about a little kid is you
just they will not admit they're tired
dude we there were there were 10 minutes
to the airport it was like must have
been like man with so much traffic but
it was like 9 30. I got there like 9 50
which is bad I'm a bad I'm bad but uh I
was so I was apologetic and I felt bad
but I got I was getting to the airport
and Calvin was falling asleep he was
asleep and I was just like dude buddy
are you tired and he's dude he's
literally like this
like dude just admit it man
you sure you're not tired I'm tired
asleep
it's so cute man
uh picked her up and he woke right up it
was so cute and we took him back when I
put and uh it's just a sweet moment you
know
being a dad's the best thing ever I know
I would say that but it is
um
I don't know what I would do though if
like my kid was old enough and he wanted
to go to the Taylor Swift concert dude
the the you see these moms and [__] that
are there and the kids are like asleep
and the moms are there for the mom and
she's like I took my daughter and it's
like dude you went for you you went for
you why is it on Instagram if you took
it for your daughter
why is it on Instagram at all if you
took it if you went if you took your son
and your daughter there
and everyone has bad seats by the way I
have not seen somebody at a Taylor Swift
concert I mean I'm talking about
everyone I see big celebrities
far away it's like stay home dude if
you're at a concert that far away just
stay home you're almost at your house
these [__] concerts were so big I
mean dude it's gonna be the highest
grossing she gave her drivers like 50
million dollars
like she's just giving people bonuses at
the Wazoo I love Taylor Swift man she
just gives people bonuses up to Wazoo
it's awesome and she just played like 19
staple centers and she just is like
I mean bro she's going to she man
I mean billions of dollars he's gonna be
worth billions of billions of dollars
she's worth like 800 million now which
but that's conservative I mean dude
she's definitely worth a billion dollars
this tour is going to grow so much I
feel I I there's the line of merch was
like longer than the line in Russia for
bread in the 80s it was Unreal
I don't even know if that's all right
uh thing but I think it is communism and
all that I have no idea dude
um
but yeah Taylor Swift killing it she
made like 50 makes like 50 million on
merch for 10 million on merch at night
or something and it's like Jesus
I'm just gonna sell Taylor Swift merch
on my show honestly that's what I'm
gonna do just her face
Taylor Swift tour and under it it says
this is it says Chris leotor
um
nah but we clean up with the merch
Department you can go get your Merchant
chrysler.com you know what's up
I don't know what the [__] is up that by
the way I when did the Emmys come dude I
gotta look this up
the nomination when did they come out
they're out nah
they're out
and and it's the 75th prime time Emmy
Awards and that the interesting thing
about that is nobody watches it so
that's good right
um and terrible shows are nominated
uh well I shouldn't say terrible actors
it's it's popular actors and popular
shows or you know
um
but dude do you know
the last dude I found this I put on
Instagram I ranted about a little bit
The Last of Us is nominated for 24
nominations
dude 25 4 nominations let's just don't
look it up let's just go through them
okay now look I know you're listening to
this you're not in Hollywood I'm not in
Hollywood I know about Hollywood though
so let's just do this
24 nominations for
um uh Last of Us okay let's go through
it all right best actor let's say
somebody's nominated for
okay
two best male actors two two female
three five that's five Awards okay there
you go
uh what else effects right
um uh cinematography script
um
uh
uh uh
uh that's all I got
now I'm struggling already and I have
three different categories and five of
them were from Best Actor oh supporting
actor supporting actors there you go
that's
ten
there's 14 left
what costume okay 11.
editing okay 12.
there's 12 left
makeup 13.
it's 11 left
audiomix 10 left
these are the [__] ones
the [__] are they getting on it but
spread the love this is the thing about
the popular shows spread the love
then if it's like dude
dude then
I found out that succession is nominated
for 26 27 Awards
[Music]
I didn't I I actually didn't even know
there were 27 Awards I'm being [__]
honest
what the f what are you nominate for
best [__] uh Teamster
see what I mean
best [__] cleaning service after the
show the [__] after a on set the
people coming the what is it this is so
Hollywood is up its own ass you can see
my Instagram about it dude it's so
ridiculous dude here here's the thing
that it's here's the thing that this is
the best thing it got nominated for
right here right here
I'm done dude
outstanding
contemporary hair styling
dude you got nominated
for running your fingers through some
hair
why are they if you're not you can be
nominated for Emma
or the queen where you gotta [__]
these people are doing their hair for
eight hours they said they did the
Patriots they go like this hey sit down
let me see here uh I'm not even
bullshitting this is what they do okay
yeah it's good you got your stuff in it
all right cool go ahead dude nominated
that's what they do that's what they do
that's what they do and they're getting
nominated for this [__] and they're
gonna jack up their price they're gonna
be like oh I got dominated from best
contemporary hairstyling hey dude suck
me off real quick that's ridiculous
there should be an a nomination for best
chilling
off off camera that's off camera work
dude this is so honestly
crazy there should be a cap for real a
show should be able to be nominated for
eight times that's it and remember the
back in the 90s you'd be like whoa it
kind of made it up 10 times dude there
there's more shows now
nominate the [__] on BET nominate some
Toby [__]
for real best commercial breaks it's on
dude it's crazy
and then what's the other one the
Wednesday one got nominated for dude
that show I have not seen I know it
sucks
and then they said beef was I'm sure
beef is good actually beef looks real
good but dude I drove past the billboard
the other day it said the greatest piece
of art I've seen in decades
hey look at a [__] painting [__]
dude what are you what it what this is
Hollywood this is Hollywood
just all day long just hey I have a suck
off meeting I gotta go I'm doing a pitch
I gotta pitch at 3 30 and then a 430 of
a [__] I have a suck-off meeting and
then uh and then eight and then uh and
then 5 30 I got a tongue in my anus
meeting the guy yeah it's a guy he's a
he's hot dude he's a he's a hot hot shot
Hollywood producer comes in just Tunes
my anus for for uh it's gonna be
probably a 45 minute meeting yeah crazy
and then I got drinks uh with some guys
that are gonna suck me off and then uh I
gotta go suck off a guy for dinner so
that's that's it that's Hollywood dude
it's unbelievable dude outstanding
contemporary hairstyling the word
contemporary just ruins it
got nominated for best comedy guest star
in when he hosted certain live you know
guy wears shorts and a blazer look he's
[__] LeBron James
I guarantee you Pedro Pasquale will show
up at the Emmys with a briefcase for no
[__] reason I I'm telling you right
now he'll show up with a [__]
a low scoop neck [__] solo that you
almost see his nipples and a briefcase
dude I swear to God and a dress I swear
a skirt I swear to God I don't know I'm
not gonna
I don't know if he's gay or not or what
or lgbtq or you know whatever the [__]
but it's like dude
it is what it is my babies
um
I can't believe it
hey shout out to [__]
a lot of sense like I'm like yeah I
almost did what that guy uh
David Guetta did with the uh shout out
to Martin Luther King Jr or George Floyd
he ended racism we're sorry for his
family here we go dude
I have a dream
I can't breathe
um
but uh I was gonna say shout out to Maui
which is so shitty you know everyone's
dying and their historic town has got
[__] exploded and I'm just like yo
shout out to Maui but uh my condolences
to Maui uh uh and it's uh it sucks
that's horror harsh right because it had
a bunch of wins and and then it started
fires and then Maui's just gone and uh
it's a historic town and a lot of the
history is now gone
and that's bad but let's look at the
bright side dude at least you get to
like uh you know start new get you know
it's because a lot of those opens they
don't have air conditioning you can make
some [__] top-notch [__] you know
what I mean like make straight up like
it's hard to get the materials in but
make places that like Dr Evil would live
like this is the thing about when
historic towns get wiped out bro this is
thank God and then you can also make
[__] crazy crazy nice like super clean
and super like I mean
you can make the illest [__]
you know
you got people out there that are like
no no I don't mean Maui but like
different places like it that happened
like oh there's been a drought in you
know Tucson for such a long time we
don't know what to do hey start over
the art there is horrible now I'm
talking about Tucson but Maui yeah my
heart does go out to people with Maui it
really that does suck I I think I don't
know people lost their lives or what but
it's so tragic
it really is
um and we make jokes and we'd be silly
but you know that's sad dude I uh I feel
bad and then Maui even people you dude
it's gonna hurt the tourism business so
bad I know that Maui too is like a huge
tourism business but man people are like
you know when Jason Momoa pops up Jason
Momoa is just like dude don't come don't
go to mad we man don't go he said don't
go to Maui and that made people want to
[__] absolutely go to Maui you know
what I'm talking about
um but he said don't go to Maui
um and you know he means business and I
still see chicks on their stories
posting that they're on vacation in Maui
in Hawaii and [__] just living it up
and that's absolutely on freaking
believable
read the room it's down deaf
best contemporary hairstyling
most outstanding temporary contemporary
hairstyling so
and then also what's the deal with the
so so man this is so funny dude
Zuckerberg and Elon it's like the fight
it their fight that is going to never
happen you know
I don't know if they know if they're in
cahoots together but dude it's sort of
what's so funny that they're just
comment calm they're just responding to
each other on each other's platform like
dude use the same one or just use one
that you both don't have that you both
don't like use only fans
but uh Zuck got upset for sure because
he was like I think we can all agree
Elon isn't serious and it's time to move
on I offered a real date Dana White
offered to make this a legit competition
for charity Elon won't confirm a date
then he says he needs surgery and now
has to do a practice run in my backyard
instead if Elon ever gets serious about
a real day an official event he knows
how to reach me otherwise time to move
on now this is my favorite part
I'm going to focus on competing with
people who take the sport seriously guy
you do apps okay hey
if what is it 40 45 hey guy
you type
and it's all good look I don't know
anything about Mark Zuckerberg except
for this fight and he made Facebook okay
and I know probably less about Elon Musk
I don't even I don't know [__] about him
but guys
the taking this award seriously is
hilarious you've done it how long two
years in your [__] backyard
I gotta see that fight It's
Entertainment dude do it in the Coliseum
for real so now so he's gonna move on
and take the sport seriously great and
by the way power to him dude I feel like
Zuck is just the kind of crazy and
go-getter and has a go-getter attitude
that could like really kind of do some
damage maybe if he started when he was
really young
but you know he looks like he's in shape
God bless dude Elon Musk writes knock
knock challenge accepted open the door
thought you might want some tea so I
brought the bags I I you know okay you
know so dorky but like don't know really
even what that means because there was
no picture or company with it but I
guess that me I guess he's responding to
zuck's Zuckerberg's thing and they're
gonna do a fight
and I can't wait dude it's gonna end so
quickly you know they're gonna be gassed
and then there you know what's going to
end it's gonna end by somebody slipping
a little bit and the other guy falling
because he got caught up in the slip and
then somebody's gonna punch somebody's
orbital bone and it's gonna crack and
and it's gonna [__] and they're gonna
have to get surgery on the orbital bone
and the doctors come out be like lucky
they didn't go blind but they didn't and
then that's it and it's gonna be in the
Coliseum you know
the Italian doctor is going to be like
oh you almost went blind but you didn't
because he doesn't hit hard enough right
because you guys make apps
um good thing that you guys are just app
makers yes
otherwise you could have maybe went
blind but you didn't because all you do
is type
um
entertainment is is [__] Bonkers and
then Trump keeps doubling down and then
the guy keeps getting indicted now he's
getting indicted for the Georgia stuff
and he's just like hey bring it I think
Trump's just like dude I'm old enough to
where maybe I'll die first before this
[__] happens right the guy keeps eating
cheeseburgers and cokes
he might
um but it's CR it
you know
I mean God damn dude they're really
coming for him I can't I can't wait to
see what happens in 2024 and also I just
can't even believe I'm oh here's what I
do know here's I'm not saying I'm not
saying I'm voting for Trump I do know
I'm not voting for Biden because of how
he treated the [__] Cuomo [__] that
dude was a [__] ass that dude was a
[__] [__] ass for
for being a [__] when somebody said
Cuomo kissed his kiss their cheek and
now we can't be the [__] whatever he
was mayor because he kissed someone's
Chi and said oh wow you look good to a
lady and then [__] Biden little [__]
ass was like oh you know what dude
forget it I can't condone that bro
you don't get to delete a vote no more
and I'm not saying I'm voting for Trump
I know who I'm voting for I may just not
vote but Biden bro you're a [__] ass
[__] for that
I just get [__]
taken out get him get the guy in the
blue shirt with the [__] dumb chains
in the podcast get him
um he called him a [__] ass he called
the
entertainment's crazy dude Sydney
sweeties Spider-Woman oh thank god dude
Sydney sweetie's hot all right good
that's it yay good she's a good actress
yay
this [__] Marvel shit's out of
control dude spider
woman
she's gonna be Spider-Woman
and Sony and
cities we need to confirmed to be
Spider-Woman and son and Sony's weird
Marvel sub Universe what does that even
mean
oh the Venom thing yeah
dude there's too many [__]
Spider-Mans by the way stop
what about just regular spiders dude
they must be in their feelings right
so many movies about yeah imagine being
a spider nowadays dude
oh this sucks
you got people talk about representation
dude we were barely in A Bug's Life and
now you got [__] they're like oh they
want dude they want
you know remember the Donald Glover
thing he was going to be Spider-Man what
about a spider
um anyway dude City Sweeney's gonna be
Spider-Woman can't wait to see can't
wait to see that gonna go dressed up as
Spider Woman and wait in line
um
yeah so anyway she's gonna do that she
said she was freaking out of course
that's cute that's cool
loving it I don't know Marvel movies are
the movies that they should be making
because it's like the only movie that's
[__] it's the only movies that are
like fantastic and you can go see it in
theater and it's [__] ridiculous but
it's like
you know
whether you're gonna [__] go see
a movie with [__] uh
what's her [__] name Francis
McDormand you know that boring [__]
where she's just wearing a [__] like
a brown jacket with too many pockets on
it
and she's just roaming around and then
she cries in two scenes for [__] sake
dude in a green room you know what I'm
talking about
you gonna go see that movie
let's see what Taryn Manning had to say
I had to pull over because I'm just like
I don't want to like cause crashes
so
rude is right
right so
rooted
I'm just like I don't really like cause
crashes because I'm just so high rooted
right now
so
oh [__]
so high
the last man that I've been messing with
is a married man and every night oh [__]
well for about three nights in a row I
haven't seen this or even maybe there's
a night in between I was licking his
butthole
dude the the meme of the [__] white
guy with a blonde hair
the [__] radio in the background dude
wow
[__] Neo moves up three spots to
number two this weekend
because you liked it
and I didn't mind doing it
because he liked it
I mean you know what does it mean like
you know yeah does that bother is that
weird yeah and that is what
demons do okay Kings your Kink demons
don't do it also there's no demons so
let's move on hey what's first of all we
are 41 seconds into this three minute
and 30 video
what where could this go
so
I was so in love so I thought so I could
buy this gentleman a boat and I and I
brought cash to put a down payment down
like I really loved him I was like yeah
it's like we're into the same thing hold
on hold on hold on so he's married
you were going to buy them a boat
I really loved him and I was like we're
into the same thing does that mean
eating his butthole that's the thing
well that's not love you know
and his wife because he's married and I
feel so bad because not I I can't stand
her okay
I can't stand her her his wife
because she wasn't even like wait what
you've been messing with my man she said
you lunatic you get out of my life or
I'll get an RO on you well she was mad
so gotta forgive her I'll put your ass
in jail anyway so I've been licking your
man's butthole for dude the best anyways
so of all time anyway so I've been
licking her man's butthole for some time
weeks on him because he he likes it a
lot and I do it to him and he comes to
me and it happens
it that's a lot I know dude her laugh is
the Jay-Z laugh right here
come on plant
it won't play it why won't the sound
plan work it just worked with this
huh I'm pissed great I'm pissed it just
worked
okay I'm pissed all good Jay-Z's life
goes like this there we go it's a lot of
information but I'm the lunatic right
well yeah
no I'm just single very single right
well
and he came to me so this may be all
made up that's the good thing about that
one thing Lee you want to put me in jail
I'll put you in jail in jail for what
your head will be spinning don't you
ever threaten me nice I actually I will
show you how I do I actually like this
don't you ever threaten me when your
husband came to me to get his butthole
licked dude this is the most gangster
[__] ever threatened me again Leanne
this is Gangster dumbass and now I'm a
turn man
I cannot believe you
lost it
lost it not I oh no dude she just been
watching like so much tutors you know
not I I brought your husband
to Newport Beach we drove all the way
together we had so much fun he had his
hand on my leg the whole time most of
the time
finger banging me I'm not gonna lie I'm
not gonna lie anymore about about it
anymore no I had no one to lose on and
and every time like in his fingers and
you're to buy him a boat
to buy him a boat dude he went on a boat
he's gonna have a boat and get his buddy
and I was gonna buy it for him gonna
call the boat the bud eater
and you're coming after me nah it ain't
gonna happen lady oh my you made a huge
here's the thing you made a huge mistake
she said the name of
you're dusted dusted I ain't scared of
you you should be scared of me well I I
hear you here's the thing about that is
she didn't make anything any word she
didn't make anything worse for anybody
but herself like she didn't even say the
people and I'm not saying she should she
shouldn't you ate someone's butthole and
their wife's mad and that's honestly the
end of that that's really the end of
that you ate someone's butthole the
life's mad well look let my gunsley
bygones you know what I mean like men
they keep [__] up but also you ate a
married man's butthole so it's like you
were gonna buy him a boat so it's like
okay you know let's just kind of Move On
Now what's happening is oh you look the
wife got mad and she started yelling at
you saying [__] you and this that the
other thing look that's bad but also let
it go find another butthole to eat you
know what I mean there's out there's men
out most most men would let you eat
their butthole uh and I mean that I
don't know probably a lot of you are
like no not most men some men it's a
weird King maybe it's not dude I
guarantee good men can be talked into
the [__] from bye bye by a woman
you know
you ever see men around sex they go like
this
can I eat your butthole what no can I
eat your ball no let me eat your
butthole
what's it feel like I don't know if it
was good people say it was good really
no I mean your butthole all right
that's how it would be
he found another butthole to eat because
at that point it's not about the man I
understand
it's about the man if you're going to
give a BJ or sex of course it is because
you want to be in love but butthole
you're all back there and stuff you're
not even facing the guy
he could fart on you it's just all
disrespectful it's not about the guy
it's about the Kink so just do that with
any guy
you know
my heart goes out to Taryn Manning
though I I feel like she probably needs
some help
um
yeah it's you know
anyway the way I've tried to get a
restraining order um against that man
that's okay I guess I don't know enough
about that I don't think it exists I
think she's just being silly let's just
assume the best right
because I don't think that that's real
oh man I would love it how about if the
lady was like it was it's me
[__]
you ate my you ate my husband's butthole
wait hold on where's Home knock me down
Hello Goodbye there you go knock me down
there you go bye-bye and then take a try
oh my having dude a
dominator in sex
this is a home run call fellow
not b
[Applause]
the salutations
bye bye and then
and then take a trot dude the [__] a
king complex dude
this is the worst home run call wow dude
knock me down
hello goodbye there you go knock me down
there you go
knock me down there you go just loves
just this guy's kinked out dude this guy
needs to get his butthole eaten by turn
Manning bye-bye
[Applause]
holy [__]
knock me down
hello goodbye there you go knock me down
there you go bye-bye and then take a try
oh there you go knock me down there you
go and then take a trot
wow that was the best
oh
wow this is worst home run calls part
one dude somebody said sounds like a
parrot left alone
that's a great dude I wish I was an
announcer that's how I would do it dude
that guy's inspiring I love that guy
that's my favorite announcer
long fly Ball Deep to Center oh there
you go knock me down dude what is not
why is he just saying country songs
these are all country songs
dude these are all [__] uh
uh what's her name songs the blonde
no knock me down
hello goodbye hello goodbye there you go
there you go be down there you go knock
me down there you go this is a country
song dude all the lyrics to a country
song Here We Go
knock me down knock me down
hello goodbye there we go knock it down
there we go and then take a trout you
that is a country song dude
reading something from Travis Tritt dude
that's the best home run call I've ever
heard in my life unfrinking believable
un-frankin believable
oh dude
this is crazy that Tory Lane got [__]
convicted a sentence to 10 years for
shooting Megan the stallions foot
dude
honestly
you deserve three years for shooting
someone's foot
who's gonna disagree honestly who who's
gonna disagree
probably the foot is the most mistaken
shot body part there is
right and wasn't he just doing the dance
dance [__] dance and shot
probably didn't mean to
10 Years bro
I I get it but whoa bro I also
if both he shot both feet
well now we're looking at some [__]
hard time actually
I you know what this is me as the judge
Tori I would love to give you only three
years but the truth is it doesn't feel
like an accident because you got both
feet so 10 years Clank
um
both feet wow okay well then it maybe
wasn't an accident
but here's the deal dude if somebody
shot my feet I wouldn't want them to go
to jail for 10 years
I might want to do a year
for real if you shoot my feet if you
shoot both feet definitely at least a
year
what do you guys think honestly how many
years should you get for getting shot in
the foot and then how many years for
shooting someone in both feet
you're still shooting a person but it's
like not a fatal shot you didn't mean to
I don't know man tough [__]
Megan the stallion is [__] dope
though remember when Tory Lanez got up
and he was the same height when he was
sitting down he stood up he's like five
six and he and he and he's got a bad
hairline but the thing is it wouldn't be
that bad if he was tall right if you're
short and have a bad hairline you're
kind of [__] but apparently but he can
spit them bars right
I mean he could really spit down bars
can he
um but why we got 10 [__] years for
shooting someone's foot both feet
what are you in here for shooting
someone's feet
imma [__] you now
I know
that's how that goes
um crazy dude sad everything's sad
but the most sad thing is Bobby and
Drake unfollowed each other
and I wish they didn't honestly just for
the [__] just for the culture you
know
we gotta see what's up with that
somebody get to the bottom of that
uh all right look well no let me
actually do some no I'm not gonna do any
well let me do some uh
let me do some of these why not
uh deserve it scales
here we go with the deserved sales
the kid tries pressing the IRL bro when
I travel on the left I'm waiting for the
day that a kid tries pressing the IRL
bro when I travel on the 11th have you
seen my IRL I genuinely want you to
fight me bro real [__] bro this is a
public announcement anyone who sees me
IRL I will give you a thousand dollars
if you beat my ass bro no one's [__]
touching me I'm untouchable hey look
whose shoes we got got his uh slacking
come on
you're kidding me
[Music]
this can't be real it is oh no
I want to do this
I'm waiting for the day that a kid tries
pressing the IRL bro when I travel hold
on he's just playing a video game
talking like this
oh God and he's saying IRL instead of in
real life
oh no dude this is
sir
you deserve this
this is the most deserved scale I can't
even believe this hold on have you seen
the IRL I generally want you to fight me
bro
dude he said genuinely
oh man he meant it too that's the
he meant it dude while he was sitting
there in that chair
playing [__]
Gran Turismo God damn it dude hey look
whose shoes we got that's that's the
best part dude that they just it starts
with hey look whose shoes we got like
dude
not even what the guy said but so good
come on bro I'm taking a video
[Music]
right oh God you a [__] right
I'm [__] I'm a [__]
everything about that is so bad
see people think they should uh buddy
put a bounty on his own head the
reaction to that was justified in my
book
[Music]
wow
and they kept their Crocs on he said
somebody said damn dude that sucks I
feel bad he's just a young kid you know
oh God that's really annoying though God
I mean you kind of want him to get at
least smacked around a little bit and
then he they took his panda [__]
dunks that is the most deserved scale
that is not that funny that I I could
have ever seen that's a 10.
oh my God IRL bro
oh this guy's oh no during the win he's
gonna hold on to an umbrella gone he's
gone this is a video game he's gone do
it oh wow you deserve it bro let the
[__] thing go what is it with people
when the wind comes they hold on to the
[__] let go
all right bro
IRL bro
a thousand dollars dude who is that kid
anyway do you even know
I mean obviously he's a twitch guy
when an adult you over this one this
one's so funny
bro he flew out
I wish I knew what that last word was
that she said dude why did he fly out
like a [__] honestly it looked like
in the 80s when they use a dummy for
this stuff
bouncing bounce dude what is he wearing
is it a cop
oh the guy's a cop dude maybe the
[__] perp jumped down that tube or no
maybe he was running after a perp and he
jumped in a tube and then came out that
one like it's Mario Brothers
oh my God
no there was a after this there was a 40
after this came out it went so viral
there was a 45 minute line of adults to
do this that's unreal dude IRL bro it
went viral and then people started doing
it IRL dude somebody said so violent for
a short slide it is man
well actually it's pretty it's not that
hot not that short
dude
heavy is the thing it must be for kids
they must go down slower holy [__]
[__] dude
that's so bad
oh God damn all right one more
uh
this guy's hyped before his match he's
hyped he's gonna be exhausted fighting
UFC or whatever it is in Peru
what happened
you heard he heard himself jumping up
and down
no
oh
no no no
um
come on dude
oh
but he didn't want to fight you know so
he lost I guess you forfeit right
what a fight for the other guy
dude we gotta watch the end so what
happens dude the medication
the medic came this isn't really deserve
it because he was just kind of excited
about the fight poor guy
hold on so he's jumping up and down
oh he [__] himself up one jump
one jump dude
there's probably better than fight you
know he would have really got [__] up
how much is he still because he's from
Peru he's just like man this was a
blessing and so a blessing in disguise
you know I could have been dead for this
you know Jesus Christ made me come
through Jesus Christ came through
for me because I would have died
probably this one you know
oh it's so bad he got well he was
[__] excited ready to go
let's do one more
oh oh this one is so funny I [__]
seen this holy [__] dude did we do this
one yet ladies car rolls away after
getting out of Cardigan place she gets
out to yell at the uh drive through
people
dude she's like get your car I think
we've already done this but holy [__]
this is so funny
what an idiot
dude what what a shot
oh
my God
um
manager dude
I oh my God bro this world is mad
she deserved to attend these are good
ones wow these are good ones I felt real
bad for the other I felt bad for the kid
and then the guy who jumped and just
broke his [__] kneecap you know let's
do one more these are good
do up to do a perfect backflip oh dude
he's in Vegas no he's not even he's
probably in Reno oh dude he did not do a
backflip that he did a front [__]
face smash
[Music]
uh ten absolute ten
10 smashed his [__] nose [__]
himself up so bad or what happened
Spencer dude get out is this 11 that's
an 11. he's
good security dude wow this is so
awesome
[Music]
he's got sunglasses on dude
this is
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas
guys got sunglasses on holy [__] [__]
this is unreal
this is unreal it's got sunglasses on
he's standing on one of those [__]
table those top high top table chairs
tried to do a backflip Falls forward
breaks his sunglasses into his nose and
mouth
sir Spencer what happened bro
[Music]
they're calling security dude that's on
what a
somebody said knowledge if you are
standing on a bar stool in the bar
Casino in a bar in a casino there is
nothing perfect about what will happen
next
oh man that is a 10.
smashed him up good huh all right well
guys like And subscribe we appreciate
you
um that is it for this episode if you
want to watch the full episode
uh go on over to our patreon patreon.com
crystalia
um and you can do that for just six
dollars uh and also you get the extra uh
episode a month and there's like 33 34
episodes so uh we appreciate you even if
not uh thanks for watching like And
subscribe baby
[Music]
thank you